Ma questa sera vi racconterò una storia
la storia di nanoland il mondo con cui
si confronta quotidianamente un designer
ma non un designer ordinario quello che
siamo abituati a chiamare designer ma un
designer quantistico
nanoleaf anche un po' la storia della
mia avventura di ricerca
come ogni storia anche la nostra storia
ha un protagonista e il protagonista di
questa storia è la luce una luce il cui
colore si può disegnare
una luce che si genera proprio partendo
da una vertigine ossia osservando
dall'alto verso il basso un mondo
piccolissimo
una luce che ha trovato delle
applicazioni straordinarie nel nostro
mondo
nanoland è una storia nata molti anni fa
dall'immaginazione
Come disse Albert Einstein nel 1929 in
un'intervista rilasciata al The Satur
dei heavening post l'immaginazione è più
importante della conoscenza la
conoscenza infatti è limitata
l'immaginazione invece abbraccia il
mondo stimolando il progresso
gli antichi filosofi come Democrito ed
Epicuro descrivevano il nostro mondo
come costituito da una serie di atomi
atomi ai quali non si riusciva a trovare
una collocazione la stessa visione del
mondo costituita da atomi perenne
movimento senza una posizione né
spaziale né temporale la riporta il
filosofo e poeta Tito Lucrezio Caro nel
dererum natura ma è solo Con l'avvento
della fisica quantistica che siamo
riusciti a capire come controllare e
come manipolare il movimento di questi
atomi
per nessuna Ricerca Scientifica anche
quella che in apparenza Può risultare
più astratta si può escludere che nel
tempo abbia un riflesso importantissimo
sull'economia sul progresso e sulla
società
un esempio importante di questa
affermazione è quello che accade nel
1960 a Teodor Maine il quale Nei
laboratori della Judge Corporation of
America inventa il laser nato
dall'immaginazione Ponendo un cristallo
di Rubino tra due specchi e amplificando
per effetto della riflessione la luce
emessa da questo Cristallo tante volte
a quel tempo quando sui giornali Apparve
la notizia dell'invenzione del laser
nessuno avrebbe mai potuto immaginare
che il laser oggi sia diventato uno
strumento utilizzato in tantissimi
settori della nostra vita dalle
epilazione alla medicina al settore
industriale
ma adesso immaginiamo di utilizzare la
meccanica quantistica e di provare a
costruire nel nostro mondo di nanoland
un laser per farlo Supponiamo di
utilizzare tanti mattoncini mattoncini
LEGO come quelli con cui sono abituati a
giocare i nostri bimbi ma questi
mattoncini di LEGO sono dei mattoncini
molto particolari sono dei mattoncini
che hanno delle dimensioni infinitamente
piccole più piccole di un capello un
miliardesimo di metro in ciascuno di
questi piccolissimi mattoncini ci sono
tanti atomi tutti impacchettati tra di
loro in maniera molto serrata e molto
compatta e questi mattoncini sono dei
mattoncini costituiti da un materiale
particolare materiale semiconduttore che
è costituito da elementi della tavola
periodica e che ha un comportamento
intermedio tra quello di un metallo e
quello di un isolante
e immaginiamo di prendere questi
mattoncini e così come si fa con i Lego
di andarli ad impilare gli uni sugli
altri minuziosamente andando a
controllarne il loro spessore
infinitesimo e andando a far sì che le
loro interfacce siano perfette che siano
allineati e gli uni sugli altri in
maniera precisa e perfetta
il risultato di questo insieme di
mattoncini di LEGO infinitesimi e la
scoperta più rivoluzionaria degli ultimi
30 anni un laser nano un laser di
dimensioni piccolissime un miliardesimo
di metro un laser che si chiama laser a
cascata quantica interamente basato sul
concetto della fisica quantistica
possiamo immaginarlo come una serie di
gradini sui quali si trovano gli
elettroni e in corrispondenza della
caduta dell'elettrone da un gradino
all'altro viene messa luce una luce il
cui colore possiamo sceglierlo e quindi
disegnarlo sulla base dello spessore di
questi piccolissimi mattoncini
e questo laser ha delle proprietà
straordinarie e un laser estremamente
potente e un laser direzionale e un
laser compatto e un laser coerente Ma
soprattutto è un laser Talmente piccolo
da essere più piccolo della punta di un
cotton fioc un laser che possiamo
maneggiare in maniera semplice e
possiamo però scoprirne la potenza
estrema andando a guardare e osservare
proprio tuffandoci dentro questo mondo
piccolissimo quelle che sono le sue
proprietà
pensate che la luce è emessa da questo
laser e una luce che non vediamo ha un
colore ma questo colore non lo vediamo e
una luce che per noi esseri umani è del
tutto invisibile
e un laser che può servire per andare a
individuare delle impronte digitali di
atomi molecole esplosivi inquinanti
presenti nella nostra atmosfera e un
laser così piccolo e compatto che
possiamo inserire persino su un aereo e
far sì che questo aereo voli a diversi
livelli nella nostra atmosfera andando
ad esempio a misurare concentrazioni
piccolissime di gas serra di inquinanti
dalla ionosfera fino alla troposfera ed
andare pertanto a servirci per costruire
dei veri e propri modelli di cambiamento
climatico
quando questo laser è stato inventato
circa 30 anni fa se devo sui banchi di
scuola Proprio qui a Policoro
alcuni anni dopo lo scienziato che ha
inventato questo laser nel 1994 ai
Laboratori a Tnt della bellezza che uno
scienziato italiano Federico Capasso
venne a farci visita all'università Io
ero uno studentessa universitaria e si
rivolse proprio a me in platea dicendo
secondo lei è possibile pensare di
impilare questi mattoncini In modo tale
che la luce emessa da questo laser non
sia solo una luce invisibile ma sia
anche una luce che non devi durante il
suo percorso una luce che passi
indisturbata dagli indumenti dalla carta
dalla plastica una luce che addirittura
possa penetrare i tessuti delle varie
cellule della pelle e dei livelli strati
epiteliali del nostro corpo e non
arrecare alcun tipo di danno
e così alcuni anni dopo con un gruppo di
giovani Abbiamo cominciato a lavorare ad
infilare tutti questi mattoncini In modo
tale da cogliere questa sfida e provare
a vedere se potevamo di fatto realizzare
un laser che avesse queste
caratteristiche
un laser che attraversa in maniera
completamente indisturbata plastica
tessuti persino la nebbia un laser che è
posta Dunque portarci Alla scoperta di
un vero e proprio mondo completamente
nascosto e Pensate un po' che quel che è
venuto fuori e che in realtà per avere
un laser di questo tipo non dobbiamo far
altro che avere della luce che oscilla
velocissima a un milione di milioni di
oscillazioni al secondo
una luce che in realtà ha origini
estremamente antiche Pensate un po' che
quando con il Big Bang il nostro
universo è passato dalle dimensioni di
una particella alle dimensioni che ha
attualmente circa il 98% della luce
emessa oscillava proprio a un milione di
milioni di oscillazioni al secondo
Ma se questa luce è invisibile a un
colore ma non possiamo vederlo l'hovia
domanda che vi porrete è come facciamo a
misurare questa luce a vedere questa
luce a capire che di fatto siamo
emettendo questa luce e così nel
meraviglioso mondo di nano Land non
esistono solo dei mattoncini come quelli
che abbiamo visto a tre dimensioni Ma
esistono anche dei materiali detti
bidimensionali a due dimensioni che
hanno delle proprietà straordinarie
Pensiamo ad una matita e immaginiamo con
dello scotch di prelevare dalla matita
tanti leggeri pulviscoli Fino ad
ottenere uno spessore di un solo
millimetro che contiene 3 milioni di
fogli di un materiale straordinario il
materiale delle meraviglie degli ultimi
10 anni Il grafene Premio Nobel per la
fisica del 2010
è un materiale dieci volte più
resistente dell'acciaio che conduce
elettricità come il rame che è
trasparente proprio come il vetro che è
malleabile si piega e si flette così
come la plastica e che addirittura più
sottile della carta e che ha una
proprietà straordinaria può misurare
questa luce invisibile può riuscire a
rilevare questa luce invisibile
e così
tuffiamoci ora nel mondo delle
applicazioni meravigliose che questa
luce invisibile può avere può servire
per un'agricoltura di precisione Cioè
per il controllo di qualità dei nostri
cibi e riuscire a capire se nel cibo ci
sono delle sostanze tossiche o
pericolose che dobbiamo evitare
può servire come sensore come lente di
ingrandimento per vedere cosa c'è nella
nostra area nella nostra atmosfera
inquinanti narcotici esplosivi può
servire addirittura per sostituire gli
attuali body scanner presenti negli
aeroporti e riuscire pertanto effettuare
una fotografia
rilevando oggetti pericolosi o sostanze
pericolose nascoste dietro gli indumenti
e ancor più interessante può servire per
un rilevamento senza etichetta del
nostro DNA
consentendoci pertanto di andare a
evidenziare tutti gli stati del legame
del Dna di un essere umano
Ma c'è un'applicazione ancora più
sorprendente che questa luce invisibile
può avere questa luce è generata da
questo laser nel mondo di nanolent per
la medicina questa luce può riuscire a
effettuare o di una diagnostica del
tumore dei tessuti molli andando
semplicemente a rilevare il quantitativo
anomalo di acqua presente nei tessuti o
per una diagnostica in vivo ed exdivo
del cancro di alcuni organi
semplicemente andando ad evidenziare un
anno 18 mesi prima della formazione del
cancro lo sviluppo del carcinoma nel
tessuto soltanto andando ad evidenziare
che l'acqua è sotto una certa soglia e
può servire in odontoiatria per andare
ad evidenziare la presenza di carie
all'interno della corteccia del dente
quello che a livello superficiale raggi
x non possono vedere
o ancora poniamoci una domanda siamo
Nell'era delle comunicazioni veloci
vorremmo tutti che i nostri smartphone
trasmettessero informazioni 10 100 1000
volte maggiori di quelli attuali siamo
Nell'era in cui si sente parlare della
banda 6G Ebbene sì questa luce può anche
servire per dar vita ad un internet dei
nanogetti riuscire ad ottenere delle
comunicazioni 200 volte più potenti e
mille volte più veloce di quelle attuali
semplicemente sfruttando queste
nanotecnologie integrate basate su
questi meravigliosi mattoncini di Lego
l'articolo 9 della Costituzione recita
che la Repubblica promuove lo sviluppo
della cultura e la ricerca scientifica e
tecnica Questo articolo è opera di
Gustavo Colonnetti padre della
Costituente che nel 1947 durante la
stesura della Costituzione fece
un'affermazione
nessuno di noi può immaginare Quali
conseguenze straordinarie la meccanica
quantistica potrà avere nella nostra
vita
la scienza produce tecnologia e la
tecnologia migliora le conoscenze
scientifiche
la no Land e la storia di un connubio
perfetto tra scienza e tecnologia e la
storia di un mondo migliore dove la
scienza e la tecnologia fanno della luce
invisibile il motore per migliorare il
mondo di domani Grazie
[Applauso]